on y trouve une huître géantes des
craintes de grands mammifères bébés
difformes et même des oreilles de
baleines à bosse c'est la chambre des
merveilles du musée pointe à callière
menaçant blaj hétéroclite d'objets rares
exotique il souvent magnifiques qu'on
appelait autrefois un cabinet de
curiosités c'est tout d'abord européen
on parle 16e 17e siècle et c'est un
phénomène
évidemment aristocratique donc c'était
de des princes qui avaient des cabinets
de curiosités
pendant deux siècles les riches et
puissants de ce monde sont ainsi
parvenus à cumuler un très grand nombre
de ces pièces dont le seul lien commun
et à d'attirer l'oeil et l'attention des
curieux
jusqu'à ce qu'on leur trouve une
nouvelle vocation plus on va accumuler
d'objets plus on va devoir essayer de
les mettre ensemble de les rassembler et
puis petit à petit on va identifier des
séries et c'est comme ça que la
classification va se mettre en place et
c'est en observant que le savoir se met
en place aussi en plus de servir de base
à la pince et scientifique moderne et au
siècle des lumières
les cabinets deviendront progressivement
les à être des musées qu'on connaît
aujourd'hui fin xviiie
on ouvre et on montre un très large
public ce qu'il ya à l'intérieur pour
son exposition le musée pointe à
callière a rassemblé plus de 15 cents
objets dont les pièces maîtresses
proviennent du musée des confluences de
lyon mais aussi de plusieurs collections
québécoises privés et publics
comme cet étrange orignal albinos ce
lièvre corps nus ou encore ses cloches
de verre habité d'oiseaux naturalisés
dans notre enfance on note tout était un
petit collectionneur de quelque chose de
petit caillou de petits coquillages mais
qu' il ya quelque chose de très très
très très lié à la nature humaine la
curiosité de nous ici normand grondin
radio canada montréal